zwar ist luca badoer herzlich willkommen
hier heute zu einem neuen video auf
einem kanal in den himmel gehen sollte
und sagt hey so was hat luca doch schon
mal gemacht ja genau vor allem habe ich
das ganze schon mal hochgeladen ich
finde unterwäsche sollte man 40 grad
waschen können aber ich war immer nur 30
grad der videokamera gut bei euch an
freunde
es ging darum dass meine mutter
wahrscheinlich so die leute sehen nicht
wenn du dir mama steht hinter der kamera
und ich habe hier einige klamotten
vorbereitet insgesamt 13 an der zahl und
da hätte man mal geben und sie muss dann
mit erraten soja der studierte ich ein
bisschen verschieben oder würde ich
sagen das ganze kostet zehn euro so dass
emotionen ja ich würde sagen wollen wir
direkt an mit diesem pullover also ich
zeige ihnen erst mal in die kamera das
ist sonja sandfarbener
natürlich ist es nicht gesponsert hier
von irgendeinem unternehmen deswegen
steht auch im werbevideo sondern wir
manchmal gerät nur ja einfach den preis
ich würde jetzt nicht sagen 19 eur 95
oder so genau richtig 1 19 eur 590 habe
damals wie christa kenne ich mich aus
das hier ist die gesamtschule immer
raten beim waschen die kordel immer so
irgendwie irgendwie auflöst und der
ganze tunnel zog dann irgendwie das war
das erste produkt das war natürlich easy
weil die marke hinten drin steht das
produkt er könnte ja dann auch relativ
das ist gemein wenn man sich ihr handy
daneben gelegt mit einer liste von den
klamotten marken und den preisen stehen
das ist sportlich aus da karmann / also
ich dachte wenn es mich
und überzieht jumper mäßig ding ja ganz
einfach mal fühlen ob cool
danke bin ich auch 100% nylon also wie
wasserabweisend parat bestimmt ne der
doch eigentlich ganz leicht von über 69
mehr
er lässt dreistellig die tat nichts
sagen 1990 80 eur 89 mächtig was her da
haben leute das hier soll wirklich
überhaupt nicht irgendwie in die
richtung neben von wegen teurer dachten
ich habe sondern es geht darum zu
schauen
mama im zuge ihres erwachsenwerdens noch
jugendliche marken was guckst du
im zuge des erwachsenwerdens der kinder
die auf dass du auch wenn du älter bist
trotzdem vielleicht die marken kennst
die wir tragen und das einschätzen kann
dabei ist nicht alt aber älter als wir
die nächste sache die ich hier habe ist
keine jacke auch kein hobby sondern eine
tatsächlich eine jogginghose von ticker
bei der jogginghose finde ich eine coole
marke jetzt auch einfach mal führen ich
trage ich sehr sehr sehr sehr häufig
diskutiert und die mich gut und dreiste
was das geht gar nicht hier durch diese
lösung auch losmachen wagen sind gar
nichts mit nicht bezahlen auch wenn wir
hier dass die produkte gerade sehr gut
reden fühlt sich sehr gut an
reißverschlüsse 69 69 120 kostet irakija
qualität hat da wirklich seinen preis
also das ist wirklich die beste
jogginghose die ich habe ich doch die
haben mir damals sogar kostenlos
zugeschickt
dies wirklich ich weiß halt dass die
unten wirklich vom schnitt her auch so
leicht und zuläuft ich weiß jetzt soll
nicht darum gehen wie ich die klamotten
befinde und bewährte oder euch die zeige
sondern sollte darum gehen dass man mir
das gerät werde allerdings wollte dass
ich euch eventuell mal in meinen
kleiderschrank zeigen und so ein paar
sachen sein gedanke juli wenn ihr euch
dafür interessiert was in meinem
kleiderschrank noch so alles verboten
ist in den geheimen fächern
erstmals schreibt gerne in die
kommentare vielleicht dadurch ja dann in
ein paar tagen ein video hoffe ich euch
eine kleine du musst dich nicht schick
machen man zieht dich ja nicht nur das
sie ist das nächste was ich vorbereitet
habe das ist eine boxershorts
tatsächlich mit hinten schon im loch
drin
sag mal wie viel ich mir die gekauft
habe ich hatte tausend mal gewaschen
vier euro von 94 95 ich hab das spiel
tatsächlich 0 euro bezahlt hat es
geschenkt bekommen vielleicht die frage
lautet ja dann wahrscheinlich vier euro
[Musik]
ich kann es auch nicht sagen die
tollsten angenehm zu tragen
ich wollte nur gucken wie du reagierst
mal gehabt aber kommen wir zum nächsten
produkte was keinen klamotten ist in dem
sinne aber es ist ein controller und der
playstation und mich interessiert
einfach ob du weißt wie teuer sein
controller ist kannst du mal für prozent
baumwolle
ja klar natürlich kann er seine ganze
damit kontrollen bisher noch 540 euro
ja der fall so ein kleiner kleines
zwischen rasen den mal aber jetzt geht
es weiter wieder mit den klamotten da
gibt es nämlich hier um ein t shirt mit
einem wie ich finde sehr sehr coolen
design sehr schlicht gehalten der
schnitt auch ein bisschen over size sehr
cool verband botanischer gärten vwg
kommt aus köln
kannst ja mal fühlen anschauen vom
schnitt design etc
bisher nicht ich weiß warum gibt es
nicht ich wüsste auch nicht wie es dann
waschen sollte die kammer bei mir schon
mit dem botanischer garten hier 100
prozent kommen
39 90 39 1935 verbracht nah dran kommen
wir nun zur nächsten sache die wir jetzt
nicht t shirt nicht rudi sind sondern
socken kann ich auch mal aufmachen hier
kann man anschauen so sieht er aus so
kannst du mal einen nehmen hier so sieht
der andere auch nachhaltig also 20 euro
20.15 eine oder zwei beide die habe ich
mir nicht gekauft die hat jule wir zum
geburtstag geschenkt hat sich nicht weil
ich die marke oft sehr sehr cool finde
ich trage die socken aber wirklich nie
so häufig weil ich denke 60 euro anm
einen ekelhaften füßen so alles muss
raus
das hat nichts mit black friday zu sein
dass ich meinen heute blue car shop gibt
es 33 prozent auf jedes produkt am black
rider natürlich aber umsichtig gehen ja
alles 33 prozent davon nicht das kommt
erst am ersten zwölfter rauskommen
punkten allerdings geht es um das hier
das ist
ich lasse dich erstmal so raten einfach
und lebt ihr das unreflektierte ein
wenig ich bin doch hier mal ein bild 1
von wem das ist wenn man wohl irgendwie
cool der taschenlampe raus ja es heißt
eine bekannte marke und gewittern
ich kenne das nicht 100% baumwolle 69
dollar
das heißt sogar nur 50 euro das ist
tatsächlich deswegen habe ich mir das
gekauft ich hatte es nie vorher an das
ist von drake das ist ein musiker das
ist derzeit der meistgehörte musiker
weltweit das ist auf jeden fall
tour merchandise also die tour klamotten
von drake das war die scotland uhr
das ist der komplette text hier sehr
cool vom non stop ist dass der text
hinten drauf dann haben wir als nächstes
etwas wurde ja wohl gemeint ist dass du
die marke kennst das hier ist der buddy
logo sollte zu kennen also ich weiss ich
gebe mir einfach ich finde sie auch sie
sollen trainings rudi von der
nigerischen holländischen
nationalmannschaft ich will nicht sagen
890 wie kommst du denn auf 298 also
umgerechnet 200 euro die sache ist die
bekommt man halt nicht mehr den kriegst
du ein reseller gerade mal wenn du die
größte bekommst überhaupt dann für 300
judas der feldarbeit 400 euro los geht
ist ein sammlerstück sehr sehr cooler
rudi finde ich ich hatte den damals
tatsächlich auch kostenlos bekommen von
freunden die seine sneaker seite haben
dass ich weit in den juli komplett
du hast dir den spaß seines lebens
willkommen wir nun allerdings zum
letzten klamotten anziehen produkt sag
ich mal also wirklich sowohl die t shirt
mäßig das ist dieser rudi ich werde mir
die musiker einwänden von dem dass die
marke ist schön dass du drauf gesteckt
sondern nicht so heiß waschen knoten
drin ja schön dick schwerpunkt also 79
kommt relativ gut ja ja ja so um die 80
euro umgerechnet würde ich sagen alles
von tyler the creator die klamotten golf
gegen sondern der seine seine zuhörer
sage ich mal hast du bist bisher
wirklich nie krass weiterleben gewesen
ach ja da wäre ich jetzt auch gespannt
das sind neue schuhe die ich habe habe
ich tatsächlich auch zugeschickt
bekommen zum glück
ich feiere das mit dem design und in
verschiedenen stoffen darauf also ja du
kannst ja mal zu nehmen kannst mal
anfassen mag ich schaue mir und dann mir
sagen was du denkst nicht wie teuer die
zu beginn waren sondern wie teuer die
jetzt sind sage ich leute die sich im
wert gestiegen und kriegst du nicht mehr
und ihr papa hat auch sein teil ja genau
also ich mach das schon paparazzi die
blazer und da lässt er das so locker
dann bei mir das nicht so die ganz herum
ja und was halt so dass die marken und
kriegst du immer so immer einmal am fuße
naja das ist komisch 250 japan relativ
genau hin also das ist ein nike air
force und der kostet so normalen neues
um die 200 gekostet interessanter ist es
jetzt natürlich zu wissen was du denkst
wie viel die gestiegen sind sicherheit
400 500 euro okay du sagst jetzt quasi
dieser schufa zu beginn 250 gekostet und
kostet jetzt zu 400 500 na ja wenn man
noch dran kommt weg geht gerade bei
2.000 dollar los also man kriegt ihn
bestimmt auch irgendwo für 1500 euro
oder so aber eigentlich trägt man
nämlich praktisch schon relativ häufig
tatsächlich finden schuhe sind zum
tragen da und ich mein egal wie teuer
der jetzt ist so der hat beginnen 200
gekostet das ist halt in krasser
schulpreis immer noch aber immer noch
irgendwo vertretbar für gute qualität
deswegen da bin ich sehr sehr sehr sehr
glücklich dass ich den auch kostenlos
zur verfügung gestellt bekommen habe und
ist ein absoluter liebling schon
wirklich ich bin ganz ehrlich ich würde
nie so viel geld für einen schuhe
ausgeben so teuer wie jetzt gerade ist
aber ich könnte natürlich als auch
verkaufen und gut gewinnen daran waren
und du christ doch kein spitz huster
drin atmet dass die das einzige was soll
mir mal das letzte produkt was ich heute
für dich vorbereitet habe ist dieser
rucksack
den habe ich mir in paris gekauft mit
julia ich habe wirklich mal geld in die
hand genommen haben einen vernünftigen
rucksack gekauft nun lena ja ja der reiz
aus schrott doch das war da fröhlich in
amsterdam anrufen hat dem muss ich
einsehen damit die den reparieren
wahrscheinlich war er ganz toll ja
deswegen bin ich auch total abgefragt
dass ich dir wahrscheinlich zurückgeben
werde ich vermute mal der konstant mit
sicherheit 400 euro ich habe tatsächlich
1500 für den ausgegeben
und ich habe mir warst du das geld her
ist macht ihr nicht so kaputt den habe
ich für 1500 lafayette balenciaga in
paris gekauft weil ich dachte hey ich
wollte schon immer ein rucksack haben
der cooles design hat aber trotzdem sehr
simples die werden das ist ein ganz ganz
simple rucksack aber trotzdem eine
bekannte marke und eine marke wo man
auch eigentlich denkt okay der rucksack
hält sich über jahrzehnte den werde ich
auch irgendwann noch tragen jetzt der
reißverschluss kaputt oder der schließt
nicht mehr richtig wenn man den ihr
hochzieht seht ihr schon da geht es dann
hier wieder auch wenn ich diese rucksack
kaufen wollt macht es nicht das ist es
nicht wert ich werde ihnen demnächst
zurücksenden
denn sagen dass ich mit der qualität
überhaupt nicht einverstanden bin
allerdings war es jetzt auch von dem
sachen erraten mama einfach klasse du
bist ja so peinlich zum glück sieht man
dich nicht nach dem halbfeld macht sie
so die energie die das team nicht heraus
wenn euch dieses video gefallen hat
freunde dann das gerne einen daumen hoch
daher ich hatte eigentlich gedacht hey
ich hab das ganze schon mal aufgenommen
muss ich jetzt nicht normal bringen aber
ganz viele leute haben sich das
gewünscht deswegen das war mama reagiert
auf meinen klamotten preise wenn sie
möchte dass ich euch meinen
kleiderschrank zeigen und in die
kommentare und so wünschen wir zogen
wunderschönen tag
[Musik]